no
like
it do make sense but uh it doesn't make
sense to disturb the
rest of the public right so
they they shouldn't be blocking the
borders or they shouldn't be blocking
the roads and this there should be a
peaceful way to do it not causing the
public any issues
i don't know like there's no other
option
other than waiting right so
let's see it's gonna hurt it's gonna
hurt the companies it's gonna hurt
like the production it's gonna hurt
everything how many hours are you
allowed to drive a day 11 hours and what
hour you want now
like uh
i have four or four hours left then i'm
out then i need to stay here for another
10 hours
are you in touch with your dispatchers
or do they know what's going on yeah
they know what's going on so well it is
what it is you know it's just
we got to grin and bear it right you
know there's just
can't get upset i'm not the only guy
stuck out here but fortunately i do have
a sleeper cab and
i feel for many of these drivers that
don't have that option and
you know
stuck with the logs and they're out of
hours and
you know and
trying to get home and unfortunately
they can't so how many hours do you get
11 today
uh 14 hours on a window time
14 hours on the clock we're allowed and
where are you now oh i'm around 13.
so did you talk tonight yeah there's no
home tonight
you know i can understand people
fighting for certain rights but the way
they're going about it this this
doing this is not going to solve
anything
all's it's doing is getting people
frustrated and uh you know at the end of
the day you know
on a political view you know
unfortunately
a person's in charge
justin trudeau at the end of the day
he's still going to be in charge
and you know i understand we're getting
stripped of our a lot of things we were
accustomed to do like going in a
restaurant
going to see loved ones in a nursing
home it's not so much all about the
vaccine and that's where a lot of the
media is putting the focus on
it's not so much about the vaccine
people are just so frustrated
of
the rights that our forefathers fought
for us are getting taken away it's not
about the vaccine it's about the mandate
yes it's a big difference yes right okay
i get it you know i'm vaccinated myself
because of my job i need to eat and
survive
and
i
respect everybody's opinions and views
that
the way i was raised
we as canadians and americans we have
rights
we're right to we're supposed to have
our freedom of speech our freedom of
religion
and they're taking that all away from us
now i'm i'm triple vaccinated i'm
pro-vaccine but i'm anti-mandate it's
time that the mandates are over it's
time that people
travel freely across the border both
sides my detroit address.com we're dying
here because of this foolishness our
customers can't come and pick up their
packages so they buy stuff in the states
all the time they buy it here they ship
it to us they come and pick it up from
us saves them a lot of money that way
but they can't get here because they
can't cross the border do you hope this
is the beginning of the end i'm hoping
this is the beginning of the end and i
think it is it's the truckers that can
do it and thank god for them stick it to
trudeau